hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast mutation detections
simplified from liquid biopsy in the
Clinical Oncology to the detection of
drug resistance associated mutations in
virology presented by dr. Dave Mitchell
we are excited to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots the leading scientific social
networking website and provider of your
virtual events and webinars advancing
scientific collaboration and learning
this webinar is sponsored by velor
Diagnostics
melih Diagnostics is a worldwide
supplier of integrated life sciences and
diagnostic solutions that help provide
customers with valuable molecular
information from scientists striving to
make research advances to technicians
reporting the information necessary to
identify monitor and treat diseases béla
Diagnostics is a trusted partner for
research and clinical laboratories
around the globe
I'm Christina jewel of lab rose and I'll
be your moderator for today's event
before we begin I would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
and any time you want during the
presentation just click on the green Q&A
button located in the lower left of the
presentation window and type your
question into the box that appears on
the screen we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation also please notice
that you will be feeling the
presentation in the slide window to
enlarge the window just click on this
green icon located on the lower right if
you have trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the support
button at the top right of the
presentation window or use the Q&A
button to let us know that you're having
a problem this is an educational webinar
and thus offers free continuing
education credits after the webinar is
over please click on the CD button
located at the bottom left hand corner
of your webpage and follow the process
of obtaining your credits we have two
speakers for you today dr. Gary Mitchell
and mr. Lu Willa Bob speaking first
today is dr. Gary Mitchell
dr. Mitchell obtained his
HD from the University of Heidelberg
Germany after two years in the private
laboratory sector he joined a buret
laboratories as a founding member and
was with Abbott Diagnostics for 18 years
right into the post a director of
medical and scientific development for
Europe Middle East and Africa he was
responsible for OM product development
and the assessment of new technologies
and had numerous product successes
including HPV HIV and cardiac troponin
eye tests that became state-of-the-art
Diagnostics worldwide for over seven
years he held the position of SEO at the
foundation of new innovative Diagnostics
find in Geneva during this time he
focused on the discovery of novel
biomarkers for use and point of care
detection of infectious diseases such as
TB and malaria mainly funded by the
Melinda and Bill & Melinda Gates
Foundation
he became vice-president of R&D and
she's technology officer at NOAA
research in Singapore in 2013 focusing
on molecular and personalized
diagnostics he holds fellowships from
the University of areas Denmark and the
German Cancer Research Centre he has
also held a number of advisory posts for
example at the WH o and the OECD he
served as a member of the German
National Blood advisory board of the
Ministry of Health and is currently a
member of several research funding
committees for example at the Wellcome
Trust in London and the Global Health
Innovation Fund Tokyo respectively
please join me in welcoming dr. Mitchell
I will now turn the presentation over to
him
good morning everybody Thank You Chrissy
for the introduction I'm Vishal I'm
talking to you today from Singapore and
Bella we'll have two presentations in
this webcast one will be on Verona
she'll do what other one will be on
oncology
so I'll start today with part one
entitled the analysis of data systems
associated mutations in HCV and HIV
using next-gen sequencing at Bella we
have developed the core technology
concept which is shown here is an
integrated workflow for NGS
next-generation sequencing and your PCR
real-time PCR and the principle is shown
here the workflow starts with an
automated sample preparation system
which we developed in collaboration with
Eppendorf in Germany and the USA has
been to options after on halo DNA has
been prepared by the by the system is it
to going to do PCR or into angeas and
these two pathways are shown
schematically on this side on this line
the after the yes a has been completed
there will be a reporting system which
is specific for these two pathways and
the software which is related to it has
been developed by by itself so it's
proprietary software in the end the data
generator can be linked to local
laboratory information systems according
to the laboratory of choice the whole
the whole system takes about on average
two lab hours to you PCR and two to
two-and-a-half days per inch in us I'll
come to this in a moment
it's free automated and the report is
also automated so you don't have much
hands-on time and this very flexible
system which can be adapted to your
local needs talking about NHS
specifically today we're talking about
an entire system which
out there for quite some time it's been
developed officially the life technology
is now thermo Fisher it's called Ion
Torrent and GS and the schematics are
shown here what layer's it's a system
that detects that detects iron flow
based on binding of nucleotides and
these reactions happen in millions of
cavities on this chip which is shown
here the so-called 318 chip which we use
in our system so what you record is
everybody event released a proton and
this proton is measured and we can
transfer into an electrical signal so
you have multiple signals every single
time millions of reactions on the chip
the nucleotides on this chip are flowing
sex eventually over the iron
semiconductor chip so you have a large
number of records at at the same time
I'm not going to much technology detail
because of time reasons there's a lot of
information you can obtain on the
internet or separately the breath flow
will develop for mgs4 HCV and HIV
genotyping is shown here schematically
the different steps are shown in the
upper panel so we starting in both in
those cases since these are on a viruses
with RNA extraction then the library
preparation template preparation
sequencing and the data analysis
reporting these are generic steps in in
this workflow the instrument is related
to this use for these different steps
are shown below
so the CentOS is X 1 of 100 it mentioned
as a robotic sample preparation system
then the us additional systems for PCR
like the Verity cycler and then followed
by template preparation on the SD for
one sequencing on the Sentosa SQ SC or
two 301 and then the C costs and some
total reporter will give you all the
data in in a in a comprehensive summary
the reports generated here are two
reports typically one is a quality
report that gives the information
the validity and the quality of the
single run that has been conducted and
the other one is a pathology report that
gives the information about the clinical
significance and change the meaning of
the of the source generated relations
are shown here is a period iterations
which are supplied by béla as well and
the software is shown at the lowest
level we have our own software
development as I mentioned and we
continuously adapting the software to to
be to the needs si si si si one
important thing for NGS which is in
contrast to a single chain detection
where the quality control is not
established this is not the same thing
for NGS so we had to develop our own
control concept here and if you want to
have more information more detailed
information or refer to this one
publication which is cited in the
headline by chat and co-workers 2016 in
the Journal of Applied Laboratory
Medicine when we published a lot of
detail about the concepts or the control
concept so in short what we have here is
15 cycles in the run this is typical for
for this for these assays we have a
system control which comprises of a high
concentration plasmid DNA and the system
control is plus it as a standalone
sample itself is shown here on the first
ring on the on the schematic on here you
can see in here and then we have an
extraction control which is the low
concentration plasmid DNA and this
extraction control will spike into all
samples this process through the whole
circle of of the SA and SC and EC curves
restriction letter template breath and
sequencing so using this control concept
we are able to control from
contamination the extraction failure
workflow failure and the presence of
inhibitors in samples
so let me proceed let me talk about HTV
inches the SI design and the vector we
developed and this is a schematic
drawing of the HTV exhibit genomic
organization what we do here is both
genotyping which happens in the NS 5 P
region because the RNA dependent RNA
polymerase off of the virus and in
addition to this we're doing drug
resistance testing or resistance testing
for testing for resistance associate
variants more precisely in the NS 5 a in
the industry regions so what you get
into one run is information on the
genotype and also on the resistance
associated variants we are using NS 5 p4
genotyping because it has been showing
convincingly in relation that this has
several advantages over they usually use
5 prime UTR religion which has been used
traditionally for HDB genotyping based
online purposes and we're not using this
region anymore because several several
several reasons one is reason which is
coming up recently only is it based in
your recombinant viruses why do we need
still HCP genotyping there has been a
lot of discussion about the introduction
of new drugs we have come a long way in
HCV treatment from the discovery of the
virus back in 89 and then the first
introduction of therapy based on
interferon subcutaneous injections three
times a week when it come to some
treatment regimen over time the maximum
response rate that was achieved in China
Taiwan was 160 percent initially was
only 10 percent so with the introduction
of the direct-acting antiviral agents
first in 2007 the first gen
and followed by the second generation in
2013 the picture has changed
dramatically now be seeing response
rates even curates in HCB of more than
90% so why do we still need to do gene
typing in RVs well as you will see in a
moment the keynote the treatment
recommendations are still based on
genotype selection and also our rabies
exists in several regions of the of the
virus and may cause some problems in in
patients especially in those who have
failed already interferon therapy there
the other reasons of failure there is
increasing numbers of baseline
resistance which is now being elucidated
with the advent of the new technologies
and most problematic is typically
typically patients which suffer from
advanced liver disease meaning cirrhosis
and if particular decompensated services
there is a strong opinion about experts
that you will also see more re bees
coming up over time due to drugs
election pressure so what these new
technologies also give you in more
detail is more precise subtyping which
has been an issue with the line
professors which are on the market for a
long time
which do not give you a very process of
talking so this little information about
the significance of subtypes especially
with the exception of subtype h3 1a 1b
which are very established by the other
sub thoughts are not been understood the
question is is there a change of
significance and we do not know this
only with the new technologies we can
now take a closer look at it and trust
no case importantly there is an in many
patients we see mixed infections which
are not very detectable by improving
assays and that is important because
mixed infections may change the regimen
for treatment so as I said genotyping is
still important as shown here this is a
summary of recommendations by the WTO
2016 and what was shown here is
typically is is a combination of drugs
usually what we do today is is drug
combination
between of one-two-three drugs typically
or four classes and what's shown here is
also the duration of therapy and which
is classified by by genotype as you can
see so you need to know the genotype to
determine the correct duration of
therapy and the selection of drugs
so China thought remains an important
factor in treatment especially because
the current treatments are dramatically
expensive still ever Graham the world
and that makes it more important to have
a precise selection of the drugs upfront
so this is a summary of the genotyping
assay we developed on NGS the major
characteristics are shown here 15
samples can be run in can be used in one
run we have one system control as I
explained the analytical sensitivity for
genotypes one to four is one thousand
international units per milliliter for
2004-2005 and six is two thousand simply
for the fact that we didn't have enough
samples to validate especially genotype
five which is a very very rare genotype
may be present in Africa so we're still
working on it
and that may change also down to one
thousand international units at a later
stage we haven't seen any cross
reactivity with a number of viruses and
you mentioned ohmic DNA reproducibility
in our ISO certified assay development
scheme was 99% the US agree to a plasma
or other anticoagulants and also serum
and the total volume is - 30 micro years
we also using the udg system which is
not a noble innovation another invention
that it's been used widely in in this
area or the control of unwanted PCR
amplify that could interfere with the
USA so it is a time for HCV is two days
the hands-on time is minimums only two
and a half hours and the sequence data
analysis is fully automated and most
recently we have added
another option pretty to the to the
software in that we can now export also
the fast a files which gives the
additional advantages and options for
your own data analysis if you do not
want if you want to do now a couple of
data on on the performance of the area
this is an early study which we
presented which was presented by
Professor COI from the Singapore
University Law School in 2015 at the
American little meeting they looked at
150 samples and using used the lam
professor which was established in the
laboratory the person HCB from siemens
and comparing the NGSS a to the to the
lab professor say they found 16
discrepant samples as shown here the
present detected the finally 90%
correctly and the NGS 100% directly on
this tape was showing that the Chima the
cheetah the recent genotyping sa
detected one be falsely the corrected
detection was the genotype six and that
was all confirmed by Sanger sequencing
so the Sanger sequencing confirmed that
all the NGS results were correct results
this is of concern since if you would
see which you would get the wrong
information about the genotype as I
mentioned before you would probably also
choose the wrong way or regimen but the
drops may fail and may have additional
costs for drug treatment interesting
here is also that in Southeast Asia in
Singapore we got the prevalence of
genotype 3 and followed by genotype 1 B
in one hand you also have a lot of
genotype 6 in this area which is not
really representative of the Western
world all right if we look at the ASM D
guidelines which came out in 2016 in
April or May time frame this year for
the first time there is a recommendation
not only genotyping which
speaking the guidelines before but also
on testing for assistance associated
variants and it's a very comprehensive
document the source is given here but if
you look at the in a summary summary
table which is shown here for the our
ABS which are detected by the Bella si
which is shown here it's bad on a 30 in
total and a 3 reach and NS 5 a and S 5
be a vision you can see that many of
these did of these of these are IVs we
have recorded in our si also recommended
by the AES and B guidelines for testing
prior to treatment and these are Abby's
are shown here in mark in orange and in
more detail is shown here especially
specifically for the ended 3 region and
as far as a region which are the most
important regions when it comes to
assistance Association variant
development the MS 5 P region has a very
very high resistance to patient and we
don't see a lot of at least not
significant in any assault provisions
are elites which are clinically
significant so again as you can see most
of the actually all of the NS v Haley
and the NSP are areas which are
recommended by the guidelines covered by
the FLSA the European guidelines which
came out recently are calling for a less
number of arabes but basically are
giving you a very similar information
now let me switch to HIV in our HIV si
we're looking at three different regions
which are relevant for treatment one is
Proteus and our K region and the other
one this is a new addition compared to
other sites which have been on the
market before we are also looking at the
integration region why is this integrase
inhibitors have been on the market for
quite some time
in many regions of the world I've not
been used very widely and that is
changing now since especially the United
States integrating
are more frequently used now so we
decided also to add it integrates
analysis into this si the number of
applicants we generating is 2 and the
target as I said our Proteus reverse
transcriptase and and and integrates the
schematic join of the HIV genome is
shown here and most of you look at our
own internal si verification results and
as I mentioned we assess developed here
under ISO certified conditions and we
are following a very precise quality
system so what's shown here is the data
on the determination of the inhalation
sensitivity limit of detection shown
here and as you can see in the upper
part of the table when you look at 2000
1000 copies per milliliter we have a
half percent detection on in this
experiment even if you go down to 500
you still have one 100% detection rate
right as when you go here samples were
suboptimal medium coverage meaning 50 to
1,000 we have yourself you see a little
bit of a drop in one at the level of
1000 copies per 5 percent and higher one
at 500 so we're recommending in our
essay a threshold LP of 1000 copies
familiar you can actually lower but the
statistical significance or reliability
then decreases you also have seen in a
crossover cross contamination study
based on 10 to the 6 copies may be
familiar in several runs we have seen no
cross over cross contamination or carry
over and in our reproducibility study we
found in 17 runs 100% this is some data
from alpha testing using this assay and
this is data from Professor button at
the tire reference center in Bangkok
they looked at 46 instrument runs here
and interesting here is that in the
Southeast Asia region we have
of the CRF or one a recombinant HIV type
which is not highly prevalent in other
areas of the world but they looked at
676 samples in total consecutive samples
from 620 CRF ones and 35 34 PPC and l1
and in one and in the Sierra one they
detected 96% correctly and the beasts
and the B & B C and a 1 the detection
rate it wasn't was 100% in the meantime
you have also data from the United
States which is not shown here based
purely on on subtype B and the detection
rate was nearly 1% confirming this data
in this study they are 22 samples which
were excluded due to low viral load or
low sample quality this laboratory has
used a Siemens which in SA in the past
is si has been withdrawn from the market
recently there's only one competitor sa
left on the market now the group looked
at the protein reverse transcriptase
used in Siemens du Chien versus Avella
si and therefore one in 199 samples 100%
agreement and RTD they found 98% Freeman
they also could QC MD testing which
passed with the 100% accuracy so this
data shows that the assay works very
well for the time being this Center is
the SI R u SS yesterday on a routine
basis some more data which we collected
also in Southeast Asia over this year
it's 3,300 perspective samples just in
2016 and when you look at the dr DMR's
drug resistance mutations diems here and
the frequencies this is the frequencies
we're seeing here is very similar to
what you would expect from using
international databases so again we had
the prevalence of high prevalence of CRF
once here in this in this cohort or not
covered in this sample collection and we
detected more than 43,000
in total with shown here is a 10% 10%
detect a frequency right here for our
key input it's due to the fact that if
you want to go down to 1% we the table
would be totally cluttered when the
integrates region which is less
prevalent we see less drm is happening
we're reporting in 1% so in summary this
is the features of the SI 15 samples as
one system control similar or the same
as for HCV as I mentioned sensitivity is
at 1,000 copies per milliliter of course
be concentrating on HIV one program nor
cross activities with a number of other
viruses and humans you know maybe the
sample volume for this essay is 700
micro litre and we also as for HCV using
plasma and serum using the udg system
total essay times two and a half days
and the hand sometimes two to five to
have two or three hours and the same as
for HIV HTTP is fully automated
we have export option for fast a file
and in addition and this is important we
have access to the Stanford HIV database
for the detection of drug resistance
mutation Bella has taken and this is my
last slide Bella has taken a license
from Stanford University to get access
to their HIV drug assistance database
which is the most important database
currently worldwide however as I
mentioned before queue to the export the
fast a file the user can also PLAs the
data against other against other
databases like the Vega database in
Europe the French database or the
affinity Chino database but this thank
you for your attention and by happy be
happy to take questions
thank you dr. Gary Mitchell for that
informative presentation it's time for
Q&A did you have a question you'd like
to ask ask dr. Mitchell please do so now
just click on the green Q&A button at
the lower left of the presentation
window typing your question in the box
that appears on your screen and click
assign button will answers many
questions that we have signed for let's
get started our first question is dr.
Mitchell do you have other virus
detection products and development or
currently available and if so what are
these products already on the market and
most of them are CD marked we also
recently got emergency approval from the
FDA for our Zika virus si in addition to
this we have CME BB BKB what and other
viruses which are relevant for testing
in immunosuppressed patients we also
have chikungunya virus we have dengue
virus and you'll see coverage as I
mentioned these three viruses a
particular have become particularly
important recently to the spread of to
to the spread of chikungunya and Zika
virus worldwide and especially the
United States where we need to know the
exact diagnosis and treatment for
instance for dengue would be very
different form from chikungunya and Zika
so this what we call the tropical panel
is currently also a very important
product for us so again yeah the
question is yes we have a number of
other virus essays on the market already
and be continuously working on on us a
it's like traffic's si which is very
well advanced now for seeker she could
go anywhere and Entering diverse
artificial beyond saving on hands on
time what benefits do you see from
introducing automation to these
workflows
well as as as known from other automated
system in systems and Laboratory
Medicine with the automation you
significantly reduce Eretz and there is
a which of a utility of huge advantage
of automated systems and general not
only to develop system so you reduce
errors by laboratory personnel and in
addition to this you increasing
precision accuracy of your results so
reliability of your results in the
laboratory provided to the clinician is
much is increasing budgets automation
system very very significantly and of
course I mean you you're saving a lot of
cost to it to the automation this is one
of the reasons why many laboratories
become highly automated today and so
it's the cost cost-saving factor in in
addition to the increasing and
increasing quality dr. Mishra you
mentioned that the work floor the
workflow is integratable with li ms how
complex are the reports that are
generated by this workflow well first of
all the reports of generating are not
complex they're very easy to understand
and very easy to read and when you talk
about the connection to the laboratory
information system in the given
laboratory our engineers would take a
look at that the the specific a lioness
in a given laboratory so there is no
general approach to connecting our
system to li ms but you would look at
this as solutions individually this is
not specific to whether this is an issue
which we have been encountering in time
the diagnostic industry for a long time
and yeah it requires a little bit of
additional work but usually due to the
experience and
expertise we have it usually works very
well thank you again dr. Mitchell we're
out of type of question but would you
like to leave our audience with any
final comment no I mean maybe last
comment on on the introduction of NGS in
molecular diagnostics which is kind of a
breakthrough in the analysis of viruses
and also as we've seen in our own
oncology the the information you're
getting here is highly comprehensive and
highly precise and with the introduction
of NGS in a routine and we have this now
at for HCV HIV on a routine basis I
should have mentioned that the see that
the h-series HCV assay which we have
introduced recently is already see a
mark in Europe it's being approved by
the TGA in Australia the record
durations in there and it also be been
approved by the Singapore authorities we
currently are introducing HIV for CT
marking validation studies are nearly
completed and so we'll have cg marketing
for HIV next year we also have this a
pre-submission for HCV to the FDA
so this essay will probably be used more
widely in the next coming months and
certainly also next year
so we look forward to working with many
collaborators and if somebody has an
idea I've got a collaboration or has
decided to collaborate with us you can
contact us directly
thank you again dr. Derek Mitchell
our next speaker is mr. Louella Bob
Lobel bob has served as the president of
Vela diagnostic since 2016 prior to his
current position at Bela
mr. will Avadh co-founded and served as
the senior vice president of research
and development and technology at Vela
Diagnostics in Singapore from 2011 to
2015
while at Roche Diagnostics Corporation
he served as the vice president of
global global program management and
business development from 2008 2011 and
as the vice president of marketing
services and sales from 2005 to 2008 mr.
Weller Bob also held both scientific and
commercial positions in several
biotechnology companies and scientific
research positions in several
pharmaceutical companies he received a
BS in chemistry from Lopes University
and was a member of the National
Research Honor Society
he completed graduate coursework being
biochemistry while at the University of
Scranton and graduate coursework in
chemistry at Rutgers University I will
now turn the presentation over to mr.
buela Bob
you
Christie thank you very much for your
introduction and hello everyone happy to
be here on the the lab roads
presentation and would like to speak to
you today was regarding a very exciting
new development within our team which is
cell-free DNA detection in oncology so
particularly what we're gonna look at
today is the determination of somatic
mutations using cell free using cell
free DNA the first thing to understand
is why why are we so interested in this
area but first basically cancer deaths
continue to increase so the key to
survival is early detection so by 2030
the American Cancer Society estimates
that 22 million new cases of cancer will
be will appear per year with 13 million
deaths annually
today in 2016 there are approximately 14
million new cases with 8 million deaths
annually so the growth rate is its
continuing expected to continue to rise
over the course of the next several
years the other important thing to note
is that at least half of the u.s.
cancers are diagnosed at stage 3 and
stage 4 okay so this is late stage
diagnosis which is which is definitely
affecting the survival rate so the key
thing is to come up with a molecular
screening technique whereby you can
detect the the early onset of cancer in
the earlier stages in the early stages
of the disease in order to provide an
appropriate treatment as soon as
possible and thereby less than the
opportunity for metastases and also to
extend the life of the individual so
what have we done we basically we
basically have come up with a system
whereby we can detect mutations either
using our next-generation sequencing
panels or our PCR or PCR assays from
just four mils of blood or plasma
specimen okay so basically the way the
system works is that four miles of blood
apply plasma or are taken out of either
struck tube or a k2 k3 EDTA tube they
are placed into the Sentosa s X 101
liquid
robot for automated extraction of
clinical samples that extraction process
takes about three and a half hours after
the extraction is done the robot is
automatic the robot can also be loaded
with either a PCR assay such as the
centers si beer a4k wrasse PCR test or
the robot can be loaded or the robot
could be loaded with one of the exchange
in sequencing panels such as the Sentosa
sq CRC panel the sq and SCLC panel the
melanoma panel or our brand new Santos Q
panel Co panel just says Goethe
mentioned in the prior presentation both
both systems have automated reporting
associated with them and we also have
the capability for the oncology the
oncology assays to utilize a new a new a
new tool for providing enhanced data
analysis through a software called third
key which is being offered through
village in omics as a service okay
globally some of the key key advantages
of our system is a selective and high
recovery efficiency of cell-free DNA
fragment size approximately hind 70 base
pair as confirmed by the bioanalyzer
the automated workflow of minimal
hands-on requirements the hands-on
requirement about 15 to 20 minutes
sample input volumes of 4 mils most
other systems on the market actually
require more than a greater than formula
input volume and the onboard extraction
is 3 hours and 30 minutes so a very
little hands-on time minimal sample
amount you can maximize the amount of
data that you're getting out of one
single sample of cell-free DNA from
blood or plasma so this sometimes SXL
free DNA extraction kit looks like this
ok so it's built for four runs with a
punch to run ok and just like the just
like the power system for the HIV HCV
that gary spoke about the oncology
system runs seven seven samples seven
samples at a time with one system
control and the kit consists consists of
a protein precipitation buffer a
conditioning buffer binding buffers wash
buffer solution buffers and then
the beads and the system control so as I
had mentioned earlier the synthesis
Excel for DNA extraction includes off
board hands-on time with only 15 to 20
minutes
we've extensively investigated the types
of tubes to be used in this system and
the three types of tubes that we
recommend for use in this system is the
k2 EDTA - which is which is used for PCR
as we started to investigate the tubes
we noted that the k2 tube was not
providing adequate results for next
generation sequencing so as many of you
know the tubes have a specific specific
proprietary have certain specific
properties to them which can interfere
with certain types of detection analysis
and so the k2 EDT - well fine for PCR
did not work adequately for for the next
generation sequencing whereas the k3
EDTA to work fine for both PCR and
next-generation sequencing the blood
storage for four hours at room
temperature followed by plasma
separation is the recommendation for
both the k2 k3 EDTA tubes for the plasma
separation we recommend centra Gatien at
1900 G for 10 minutes of 4 degrees C
followed by plasma clearing another sec
centrifugation step at 1600 G for 10
minutes ok and then after that the
plasma can be stored at minus 20 or
minus 80 degree C for the sample type
whole blood we're recommending the
strict tube for that which is stable up
to 48 hours at room temperature before
processing for the sample input volume
with 4 mils so again we're transferring
the clear plasma to a 5 ml Eppendorf
safe lock tube adding 266 microliters of
the protein purification
buffer and vortexing for 15 seconds
Center for centrifuging that at 6700 G
for 10 minutes transferring the
supernatant into a 5 ml exigence
crew-cab tube and loading it onto the
center's Essex 101 liquid handling just
some with the 5 ml tube I provided by
Eppendorf the
six 101 will then add in the controls to
the samples for the next generation
sequencing assays so this entire process
I just described takes roughly about 15
to 20 minutes okay once the once the
once the plasma is on the on the deck
the robot the first thing we do is we go
through a binding procedure which is
automated by the SX 101 okay
seconds followed by a second binding
procedure on the s6 101 followed by the
washing procedure okay and then finally
the drawing evolution procedure on the
SX 101
okay so through this this procedure
takes about three and a half hours as I
had mentioned earlier and with a
hands-on time of loading the robot for
about five minutes with the program with
the desired consumables the other
sometimes OS X 101 robot is set up by a
computer prompted Dec layout basically
the computer will prompt you to what to
put on the deck and where to place where
to place each component on the deck okay
so we have we have the consumables for
the reservoir rocket three at position 5
and that is where we place our system
controls and then all of the buffers are
placed into a set into a separate the
rack on the system ok so after we do
this what does what does the data look
like so after we've provided the
cell-free after we provided the
cell-free DNA preparation we've then
taken that we've then taken the the the
prepared samples into our Sentosa sq CRC
panel for looking into our suppose osq
CRC panel and since those sq CRC panel
what we did was we actually we provided
we took this we took we took negative
plasma material and we spiked we spiked
that negative plows material with known
quantities of cancer cell line and this
is the results that we obtained for
force seven individual samples remember
there's always one control associated
with this
as well okay so for the sample number
two we detected the v600e mutation and
reported the variant frequency at twenty
seven point seven percent okay
whereas running side by side with a
syllabic silica-based column extraction
method only wild-type was detected all
right again looking at samples three
okay
fifteen percent and then all the way
down on sample for to a four to
approximately 4 percent mutation so very
very low very very very low frequency
mutations it will be detected with the
system down to four percent if you look
at the bottom table the bottom table
describes the median coverage that was
obtained from the sequencing system so
we're looking at an approximately
million coverage of roughly around two
to three thousand reads for the
detection of each one of these
particular mutations so after building
some control samples we actually we
actually obtained some plasma matched
plasma and FFP material from two
commercial vendors geneticist and
capital biases Sciences with various
stages of its various known stages of
cancer being present okay so in the
first of a samples we notice that in the
end we notice basically we're looking at
the detection of wild-type and we
detected wild-type down to a level of
approximately one point four nine and
one point one one nanograms per library
prep okay so very low input amount of
material detecting wild-type the next
sample was a stage three sample material
with two mutations present with a
mutation president KS 3581
the plasma observed mutation was also
the same as the EPI notation and again
note the number note the amount of
nanogram for library prep at point four
nine
likewise for the following samples we
also detected a tp53 mutation pik3ca
mutation and two additional Kaos
mutations they again down to a very low
amount of material per library prep so
the panel of the panels though a penile
that was used in the system was our was
our colorectal cancer sample which is
targeting eleven clinically-relevant
genes in 113 hotspots so when you're
monitoring when you're monitoring say a
disease or a known known affliction
using one of the smaller cancer hotspot
panels is very very prevalent amongst
our amongst our customer base okay so
this is a smaller panel for searcy or
even the smaller panel for NSC LC these
panels basically have have about
approximately a thousand X median
coverage all right
run seven samples one system control can
be used with one 10 micron section of
the 50 material or in this case 4 mils 4
mils of plasma okay so very very high
sensitivity high reproducibility at a
thousand X coverage for these panels and
these are for high prevalent mutate high
prevalent mutations okay so this is
where you're not looking at these our
hyperbola mutations as determined out of
the cosmic database okay so the next
panel we have is also is the center's s
key melanoma panel again thousand x
coverage covering on the high problem
you tations
associated with melanoma but you know
that has determined out of the cause of
the cosmic database okay
so again if this if you're monitoring
your specific if you're monitoring a
known case of melanoma over treatment
this is a desire panel to use the next
panel
Sentosa sgp inalco panel and this panel
contains high and low prevalence
clinical mutations on 70 genes including
3 whole genes okay so this panel was
designed in mind of looking for for high
and low prevalence clinical mutations
unlike the other panel which is designed
more for poor known clinical mutations
with high prevalence this panel covers
both low and high prevalence do you
notice on this panel the median covered
just 500 X with a minimal coverage about
300 X covering 67 hotspot genes 3 whole
genes and 300 Q on amplicons
utilizing 7 samples per run plus one
system control ok so this is a brand-new
this is a brand-new product from NOAA
and what we're doing with this project
we're actually offering early access
program for cell free DNA kit available
for PCR or for next generation
sequencing the next steps in our next
steps in our progress toward toward the
continued enhancement of this kit is to
work with additional match FP and blood
specimens in order to continue to drive
down the level of detection the level of
mutation detection and also to look at
how low we can go with consistent
detection so I showed you examples of
down to about 4% right now and what
we're doing in our current research is
taking those down to under 4%
approaching 1% mutant allele frequency
from the initial results you can the
initial results that I've showed you can
see that is possible to automate cell
free DNA isolation and library
preparation on a single robotic workflow
and detect some addict mutations from
NGS that are very at a very low
frequency with a very low sample input
amount but that being said I'd like to
ask for it I'd last like to ask if
there's any questions from the audience
where I can continue to I can continue
to explain the system in the greater
manage eater
Thank You Liam for that important of
presentation it's time for Q&A we want
to get right to your questions and input
so here's a reminder how to let us know
what you have to say questions and
comments can be submitted via the Q&A
button in the lower left we will try to
get to all of you but if not we'll be
sure to follow up after the broadcast
let's get started our first question is
Lou
can your cell-free DNA kit you use with
Illumina sequencing systems Thank You
Christy yes the cell-free DNA kit can be
utilized with systems beyond the Velo
panels I showed we have work we have
worked well with the Illumina with the
Illumina platform in conjunction with
both our FFP extraction system as well
as our cell free DNA extraction system
we're in we're in the process
so we're in the process of testing that
today the news the new panel the panel
Co panel is also in early access at this
time but the our goal is basically to
have the cell-free DNA workflow work
across the panel Co panel and what we're
particularly looking at right now is is
to look at the rare variants at low
frequencies for the for use on that
panel and to see how we are able to
detect those at the 500x median coverage
now do you plan to offer Gina Gina
fusions in your uncle panels in the
future
we see gene fusions as a very very
important as a very important prognostic
and so we do intend to include we do
intend to include gene fusions for al
cross and ret into our panel in the
future how does the early access program
for the cell-free DNA reagents work do i
need to purchase instrumentation or will
Vella make instruments available for the
cell-free DNA for the early access
program for the cell-free DNA we will
work with the we will work with the
interested party to provide them with
not only the kits but also access to our
instrumentation for the politican and
for the detection if that's what the
desire is an audience member question
they say if I'm not mistaken you've said
about four to five percent sensitivity
and mutation detection against WT
background isn't it too low from liquid
biopsy so four percent
detection so our idea here is that we
know that low-frequency mutations are
becoming increasingly important okay and
so we feel that being able to provide
low-frequency attention to the community
is important to monitor disease
progression and to even potentially look
at early disease progression so we don't
we feel that although the guidelines
today are showing higher okay
may show higher mutant allele
frequencies as being clinically relevant
we also have been working with
collaborators who tell us that we should
basically be driving those mutant allele
frequencies as low as possible because
they are seeing they are seeing early
clinical they are seeing clinical
relevance of those in in many of their
and many of their patients today
if there are no more questions I would
like to once again thank mr. Lubell
about for his presentation low do you
have any final comments for our audience
no just that I think
technology really this technology really
is the next generation we've always
talked about what the next generation
sequencing was what the next generation
detection was but here's a next
generation pre analytics that I think
has wide-ranging opportunities to really
improve the level of healthcare bullet
thank you once again mr. Louella Bob and
thank you to Vela Diagnostics for making
this presentation possible before we go
I want to let everyone know that today's
webcast will be available for on-demand
viewing through February 2017 you will
receive an email from lab roots letting
you know when this webcast will be
available for replay please share that
announcement with your colleagues who
may have missed today's live event
that's all for now thanks for joining us
we hope to see you again soon goodbye